It is about cultural relativism,
that's what this discussion is
essentially about Western values as we
understand them,
not just practiced in the west practice
in the large number of places,
but usually called Western values and a
shared common universal values coming
from different traditions and then we
can share
the meaning of
Christianity and other religions and the
Jewish tradition.
So this is a point which is quite
important and it has nothing to do with
cultural relativism.
There are no jokes in Islam.
As famously said,
the West is able to look at his foibles
and laugh to make fun of his fundamental
principles,
but there is no equivalent as yet of
monty python's life of Brian.
Can we look forward to the life of Mo
when one search this,
this notion is ludicrous notion of
racial or cultural or value superiority.
One is really denying all of the cross
cultural wealth of our human legacy.
We would,
we would throw out half of the poetry of
gutter who was inspired by the Persian
poet Hafez and then we've.
We would,
not that anyone here would read it,
Bob,
but we it ball,
who was inspired by Gerta and wrote
poems and honor of gotTa.
This is a cross cultural that what God
himself called the East West Duwan where
we could all sit together and exchange
our cultures and exchange our values and
exchange your ideas.
If you go into that table to sit down to
dinner with another man and or another
woman and say,
I am superior.
You don't have a dialogue.